hi there steve here again this is the
11th in this series of 12
videos
a course to get you going to get you
through your 90-day challenge but also
to give you something that you can refer
to that'll keep you going
in in learning your language and take
you through success
using link of course or however you
study a language today i want to talk so
today and then next week i want to talk
about
the kinds of things you can take away
that are going to ensure your success in
the long run and today i want to talk
about curiosity there's all kinds of
research now that when we are curious
about something
things happen in our brain which make us
more receptive to learning whatever it
is we are curious about
so you have to try to cultivate
that curiosity and to take advantage of
your curiosity so it begins with your
curiosity about the language
are you curious about
french japanese chinese arabic whichever
language you're learning
are you at least curious about some
aspects of the language or the culture
because this is going to make it easier
for you to learn the language if you are
curious about it or conversely choose a
language
that you are curious about or whose
culture you're curious about to work the
curiosity uh similarly when you are
studying the language
find content that you're curious about
whether it be
you know japanese anime or korean drama
or soap operas from colombia or whatever
it might be find something that you are
curious about
another thing that helps in order to
stimulate curiosity is listening when i
listen
and that's my biggest learning activity
by far in terms of time
and i hear things that i don't
understand
that makes me more curious to find out
what those words were so when i'm
curious about the words because i've
heard them maybe more than once and i
didn't understand them i'm more likely
to remember them so there again
listening and hearing words and phrases
that i don't understand stimulates my
curiosity i then go and study those
lessons in length and i'm more likely to
remember
similarly with points of grammar
uh very often if we get a lot of
information up front about how the
language works and we don't quite notice
or remember or understand much it's too
early for us however when we have been
confronted with certain structures in
the language that seems seem a bit
strange
and then we're curious about them so
then we look them up we might look up
verb conjugations or we might look up
different aspects of the language
and
then we're more likely to understand the
explanations and possibly remember them
probably we have to look at them again
and again but at a moment when we are
curious about them because we've come
across these things in our listening and
reading so if we can look these things
up while we are curious we're more
likely to remember so anything that you
can do that's going to trigger that
curiosity and any opportunity you have
to take advantage of your curiosity is
going to help you learn better
and you may want to if you're curious
you may want to google
curiosity and learning and you'll read
them in great detail how
curiosity is a powerful
motor
and a powerful condition for learning
and so you should be looking for ways to
utilize curiosity in your language
learning
thank you for listening and we have one
more week to go and in that final uh
video of this course i'm going to talk
to you about how you become a lifelong
learner
so thank you for listening and i hope
you're curious bye for now